le musée léon dierx
dans les années
40 le notable gustave madness construit
une demeure particulièrement original
rues de paris en 1911 le conseil général
à leurs propriétaires de la maison
décide de la transformer en musée
sculptures tableaux objets d'art et
autres souvenirs historiques forme le
fonds initial le 12 novembre 1912 le
musée léon dierx second musée créé à la
réunion ouvre ses portes durant la
première moitié du 20e siècle le
bâtiment dégradé par les intempéries et
souvent restaurer mais en 1963 la
situation est grave
le musée doit être démoli pour être
reconstruit en 1965 un nouveau bâtiment
est inauguré l'accrochage des oeuvres a
été optimisé si le portique avant et
reconstruit à l'identique les autres
façades affiche des lignes résolument
contemporaine
la nouvelle architecture du musée est à
la pointe de ce qui se fait de mieux en
la matière à l'époque c'est la première
et l'unique architecture muséale de ce
type
construite à la réunion
le projet confié aux architectes jean
hébrard et daniel de monfreid d' alors
en charge des bâtiments publics pour le
département comprend aussi des bureaux
des réserves et une grande salle pour
les expositions temporaires notamment
dédié à l'art contemporain
les collections du musée enrichi par le
don d'ambroise vollard en 1947 aborde
les aspects les plus novateurs de l'art
du 19e siècle et des premières années du
20ème siècle